in this project we'll look at what
happens when you try to scale the small
world we've been building
into gigantic earth and beyond size
planets
specifically we'll be covering using
floating origins to build even bigger
procedural worlds
the problem we're trying to solve is
what happens when i take my dinky little
world that i've been building up until
now
and try to jack it up to earth sized and
beyond
the answer it looks like crap so
today we're going to be exploring why it
looks like crap and how to start fixing
those issues
now just to recap we've been building
out a series on 3d world generation
and procedural terrain in javascript and
3js
there's an entire series to catch up on
if you haven't already
starting with basic mesh generation
using height maps planetary scale level
of detail
advanced texturing techniques and
approaches to threading
it might seem that we're pretty much
done now with the whole planet
generation thing
time to go make no man's sky
or maybe not the reality is is the
planets that we're building so far have
been
more like dinky little asteroids and
moon sized ones
so how do we build something bigger
before we begin make sure you've
subscribed to this channel and on
twitter so that you're notified when new
videos are released and you can also get
previews of what's coming up
so then how do we make this
significantly bigger
easy we just go back into the code here
and there's a constant
up here in terrain.js for a planetary
radius
right now it's set to about 4000 meters
or so let's jack it up by adding a bunch
of zeros
obviously since you're watching a video
about why and how to fix this
just cranking the number up is going to
fail so we'll load it up and at first
glance this seems to be working out
planet is goddamn huge now we really
have to crank the camera speed to get in
but as we zoom down to the planet's
surface we start seeing some major
problems
going right up to the ground now this is
probably about as low as you'd go
to place a character down and this looks
like garbage
the ground is shaking and shimmering and
just going nuts
so what went wrong
let's take a step back and refactor the
code a bit before diving in
since we're going to be playing with the
planetary radius often
let's move some of the variables that
are scattered throughout the code
specifically i'm talking about the
constants declared at the top of
terrain.js
the ones hardcoded into graphics.js and
the top of texturesplatter.js
the problem is every time we want to go
change save the height of the terrain or
the size of the planet
we have to remember to go screw around
in multiple places
instead we'll create this
terrainconstant.js file and just cram
everything in here
now if we want to go change the terrain
height it's super easy
just change it here now we can load it
up and see the change
i can go back in here change the radius
of the planet from 4000 to 8000 and
voila
again it's all good even the scattering
implementation picks up the changes
alright with that out of the way let's
go back to figuring out why this looks
so bad
let's check the size of the planet back
up now we'll wait for it to load and
let's move around a bit
first thing you'll notice is the
texturing seems off but switching to
wireframe you can see that it's not just
the textures
as i pan the camera around slowly look
at the mesh
the triangles themselves are jiggling
around and going a bit crazy
keep in mind that i'm not moving the
camera at this point so there's no
recalculation of the mesh happening
to understand what's going on we need to
take a step back and understand the
representation of numbers in a computer
all of our meshes are using floating
point numbers
floating point numbers are fantastic
tools in programming
they're super useful at representing
things like positions
directions texture coordinates but they
do have their limitations
understanding these weaknesses is the
key to fixing this problem
let's look at how a floating point
number is defined
a 32-bit float consists of a sine bit
eight bits of exponent
and 23 bits of mantissa or in other
words the fractional part
the problem is with the mantissa or the
fractional component
there's only 23 bits of precision there
which
in general means that you get roughly
six to seven digits of numerical
precision
let's run through some quick examples
say i have the number 10
so the corresponding float looks like
this which means basically it's 2 to the
power 3 times 1.25 which equals 10.
now let's do 10.001
this is a little bit more complicated
that number isn't perfectly represented
by a floating point number
so this ends up being 2 to the power 3
times 1.250125
etc and notice that it's not exactly
10.001
it's actually 10.0010004
and a bunch of crap this is an important
point
floating point numbers just try to get
you as close as they can
so now let's watch this fail really hard
and fast when working with positions
let's start with a position let's say
that you're at 10.0 on the x-axis
now in floating point if you recall
everything is fine
and you get 10.08 exactly if i move a
millimeter that's going to be 10.001
and a bunch of crap so close enough
that's fine
so far everything is good enough for a
game we're off by like a millionth
who cares but now let's scale that up to
planetary numbers
so the new x coordinate is now one
hundred thousand
remember when i said they only had about
six to seven digits of precision
that means if you add .001 or one
millimeter
to a hundred thousand in floating point
you end up with
a hundred thousand you completely lose
the point zero zero one
because there just isn't enough
precision to handle it
you might be thinking but javascript has
64-bit floats not 32-bit
yes javascript does but the bottleneck
here is the gpu not the cpu
and we're dealing with 32-bit floats
there and using doubles everywhere
also doesn't fundamentally fix the
problem it's just a duct tape solution
let's talk about some strategies to fix
this
one super common approach is using fixed
point numbers
these are basically integers that you
treat as if they have a fixed fractional
component
they're amazing for reliability but
that's a deep
change to the code to support this
instead let's go back to that original
example of 10.0
notice how near the origin adding all
these small numbers works fine
near the origin doing calculations is
going to easily give you sub
millimeter accuracy but the further you
move away
the worse the accuracy is so
i'm going to make a big jump here what
this means is
if instead of calculating our meshes and
world as if they're at some static point
in space
we calculate everything relative to the
position of the camera
this is called having a floating origin
and the gist of the approach we'll use
today is that
when we go to generate a chunk of train
let's say the camera is here
at position xyz which is super super far
away from the origin
if we were to generate the mesh in
absolute coordinates at this point it's
going to be a mess because of precision
issues
instead we'll treat the camera as the
origin and move the world around it
instead
so we'll be generating the mesh right by
the camera and then as the camera moves
we'll actually just offset that chunk of
terrain in the opposite direction
in the end it comes out to exactly the
same thing visually
but it allows everything close to the
camera to use small numbers
that can be represented more precisely
by floating point numbers
let's get this all into code the first
thing we need to do is go modify the
worker code to generate meshes relative
to a new origin
all the mesh generation code is done
here in the terrain builder threaded
worker.js file
we get a message down here from the main
thread that tells us to build
mesh and this rebuild function takes
care of generating all of the new
positions normals that kind of stuff
there's also a bunch of parameters here
that are passed down from the terrain
class
stuff like the local the world matrix
the mesh resolution
radius of the planet etc we'll just add
a new parameter called
origin and this will be the origin that
will build the particular chunk of
terrain relative to
after that it's a few simple changes to
the position generation previously we
used to generate all of the mesh
coordinates in a local space
and then rely on setting a group
transform to move them to the right
world space position that's nice and
simple but it's also part of the problem
so back here in the terrain class we're
not going to set the group's transform
anymore we'll be generating the mesh and
transforming it ourselves
now in the loop down here we take the
position and apply the local the world
matrix to move it into world space
and then subtract the origin here this
effectively brings the positions back
close to the origin since we pass the
origin through the parameters
we have to actually go back and thread
this through these parameters are passed
from terrain builder threaded so
here in rebuild chunk we've got all the
parameters being packaged up for the
worker
most of these are actually passed
through from above so we'll add the
origin here on this line
and then we need to go up a level in
terrain.js there's a function here in
create terrain chunk which is
responsible for
calling the builder to create new
terrain chunks and it's here that we can
add the new origin parameter
all we need to do is pass in the current
camera position
now remember how all of the world
geometry is generated relative to the
camera
that means we need to render as if the
camera is centered at the origin
so in terrain shader we need to modify
the view matrix
specifically we'll need to create a new
terrain camera matrix that will be
mostly a copy of the current view matrix
but set at the origin there's one last
little change that we need to do here
and that's in terrain chunk.js
we need to set the position of each
chunk relative to the current camera
taking into account the origin if you
remember our drawing
each chunk was generated around the
origin and as the camera moves we need
to calculate the delta between the
terrain's origin point
and the current camera position what
that means is we'll need an update
function here in the terrain chunk class
and we'll just subtract the current
camera position
from the origin and set that as the
position for this chunk
and that's it just some relatively
painless changes and once we load it up
the train isn't all jittery anymore
we can zoom in and out now and there's
no catastrophic issues with the mesh
now obviously this isn't the only hurdle
we need to fix
the train still looks like garbage since
the texturing follows the camera around
since the position is local to the
camera
i think we can fix that in the future
more easily by passing down some
repeating world space coordinates or
something like that
the seams are still there in the terrain
yeah i'll fix those at some point they
just need a skirt or something to fix
those
and if we zoom out far enough well first
off the planet
doesn't really look like a planet now
does it it looks like a splotchy green
and brown thing
but even just ignoring that if we go far
enough
this happens kind of looks like it's
really hairy or it's on fire or
something i don't know
anyway we've hit the limits of the far
clipping plane so we need to do
something about that too
baby steps we'll get there eventually
next video in the series will address
more of these issues
hope you enjoyed this if you haven't
already subscribe both here and on
twitter
you'll get notifications for when new
videos drop and previews of what's
coming up soon i also chat with people
and try to get a sense of what you want
to see next
make sure to like the video and leave a
comment about what you want to see
covered in a future tutorial
the code is all up on github so knock
yourself out like always do whatever you
want it's free to use
if you don't understand something feel
free to ask
cheers everyone